back in the day when I was coming up it
was major labels is a few artists you
picked who you like and that's what it
is with the internet it's a wide range
you know what I'm saying a lot of people
just upload music and you can jess for
free you can just check it out you know
I'm just up to you if you like it or not
that's it I'm ecstatic to be with foods
go that's the label that I wanted to be
yet they catch it up a track Ben does
that's my family you know what I'm
saying and they just give me all the
creative room I need to work on projects
and to do what I want to do and that's
hard to find in the label artist
relationship you know they kind of trust
my judgment and I trusts me and I trust
a judgment doing some since you know
that's why I wanted to be my manager
asked me what label did I want to go to
I said who's go he bumped it took Nick
catching eels at a burrito spot and the
rest is history nice like my all-time
favorite rapper then you know coming up
I would say like dizzee rascal is a huge
influence like e-40 Andre 3000 you know
if it wasn't for dr. Seuss books I don't
know if I'll be here you know so shops
out to the cat in hat I kind of joke on
rappers and I call them cat nahan
rappers guys that use ABC rhyme formats
predictable predictable rhymes and stuff
and I try to be a little unpredictable
on my rhyme schemes and my patterns and
stuff so i don't know i think i would
say dr. Seuss on steroids maybe you know
right now I'm working on get my show
together better we'll see how it works
out here today you know but you know
I've been doing a lot of shows lately so
I just been writing songs in between and
I'm not really like a studio right kind
of guy like I write a lot so I just
write a lot of songs when it's time for
me to get some time I go in the studio
bang it out their album fry taking like
two weeks maybe you know